Welcome back. This week in Six Week Renew. It's our last week and I really want you guys
to use all of your skills together for this week's exercise. We are going to talk about
the concept of reward. So our exercise for today is to set up this jump course or a jump course
and we are going to start the horses with one jump first. One at a time both directions with
a reward in between and then we're going to build up to a full course. So we have two different
horses today. This one is a well-balanced horse that doesn't need a lot of adjustments but that
has more energy and fitness and the second horse is needing more help with balance,
has lots of energy and needs more breaks. So you're able to do this exercise at any level.
You can start with poles on the ground, you can move to small cavalettes or cross rails,
whatever your level is do it at that level of you and your horse. You can be starting in the trot
or the canter. The point is to find a way to reward the horse at the right time when they need the
reward. So here's our first break we have with this horse. We've gone a little bit both ways and
now we have a long walk stretch. You can tell this horse knows what to do on his break. He's
stretching out long, he's pumping his neck around and he's ready for the next jumping and gets
excited when he's ready to start again. So kind of stage two after you've jumped something maybe
like cavalette size would be to go to a bigger jump or a different one and jumping it again
one jump both ways and recognizing what kind of style is the horse asking for right now. Are they
happy to go forward? Are they feeling energetic? Use that. Are they feeling tired? Maybe you need
to instill more breaks in the horse. Are they feeling overzealous or overachieving? Maybe you
need to regulate how much they're jumping today and tell them that you might know better than
they do. This horse is quite eager to jump and so at the beginning here he's getting quite a few
breaks. The breaks might be very short maybe only 30 seconds to a minute and then we go back to the
fun part for this horse which is leaping and now he's doing a little combination. So this at this
point we recognize the horse is very excited to jump and he needs something to do. So now we've
built up into two longer combinations nothing too squishy the jumps are not too big and he's
just jumped a little course and now he's getting his break in a slightly different way. So you see
me candoring loosely and petting him for his break since he's so excited. This is a nice way for you
to reward the horse without having to kill their fire if they're very happy to do their job. So he
gets a little canner break there and then he begins a little bit of jumping. Again single fences to
double fences. At this point he's jumped quite a bit so it's important to give the
physical body of the horse a little bit of a longer break. Mentally he's very excited he's
happy that he got to jump several fences in a row and that's part of our jobs as riders as coaches
of the horses to be sure we're reading them and we're taking into account what they say. If this
horse is excited to go and do his work we don't want to take that from him but if he's jumped a
few fences and we've noticed that it's been an effort then we want to give him a longer break
for his physical body to catch his breath but also for his muscles to let down so that the next set
of jumping just like you would do in your own exercise is better with better form and better
clarity. So now that we're done our long break there with this horse we're able to go again and
potentially do maybe a full course or a half course.
So you can see there after he's done his full course there now we can really reward him he's
receiving the pets you can see his ears are up his expression is loose his tail is swinging these
are all indication the horse is very happy with themselves. Make sure you read your animal listen
to them and understand what they need as far as reward. Horses love to be rewarded for an effort
they're making a physical motion they're making or even just a mindset they might have. So now
moving on to this horse this horse typically likes to do shorter versions of work every day
and not too many breaks because she loses her mental focus. So we'll see what kind of physical
rewards we can give this horse while still playing by her rules of her most her best way mentally.
So we're always going to start out with setting this horse up if your horse is like this you're
going to spend time between the fences you might ride your course with say a circle or several
circles between fences to set up the physical anatomy of the horse for better jumping technique.
So for example here the horse is going to do a circle to set itself on the on the left hind leg
and you can see she's struggling with that so she needs to have find her flat work between fences and
us as riders need to allow that to happen and reward them in between. So we might be
jumping less fences with this horse and getting more accomplished. Here we see that set up a
little more closely with the right hind coming underneath her. Another common setup that horses
might need is just simply outside flexion after the fences they need to go into the outside aids.
So if you're operating on a level where you're just getting outside flexion after the fences
you're going to do the same program as this horse even though this horse has advanced to haunches
in to get her balance which is a little further along than just outside flexion. So if you're
less further along than that you might be circling and resetting your horse the same way that this
horse is going along and rewarding them for their setup and less and less rewarding them for the
jumping effort and more rewarding them for the setup of the jumps. So now this horse we have our
first little break and we give her still a little bit of something to do on her break since her
mental focus is wanting to remain present. If your horse is like this play by their rules they want
to stay focused they're not trying to be bad horses they're trying to tell you how they learn the best.
Beautiful job there on this horse. So now we've integrated to be able to do two fences in a row
and the horse is balancing beautifully landing and reclaiming their balance much better
all because of the work that we're doing after the jump. There you go perfect.
Again this horse does not appreciate being pet as much as the other horse so know your animal as
well. This horse doesn't want to be bothered by being pet she wants a voice command of saying
good girl or good boy if you have a boy and some horses don't want the distraction of being pet.
Other horses need the touch the physical touch of being pet so play around with that and make
sure that you're talking to the horse in the language that they speak already.
Beautiful job almost a full course with this horse already and a second break here and she's
actually relaxed into her second break physically even better so that tells you that the method
even better so that tells you that the method that I'm playing by her rules of keeping that
mental focus is working and there she told me that she was ready to go again she wants to maintain
her mental focus. Good and you can even see from this angle the the form over the fences is getting
better because of the style of communication I'm using for her to be able to ride her best.
Again there that reset of balance happens first from outside flexion and then haunches in.
I'm so excited to watch your videos and see the product of everyone learning to
communicate with their horse the way the horse wants to be communicated with.